hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the moral
vocabulary and our deliberations and
discussions of our own time we won't
allow you to to frame things between a
country in a contrast between egoism on
one side and altruism on the other side
egoism meaning something like placing
oneself first being primarily motivated
by how things affect one's self altruism
being merely its opposite or you know
you might say it's logical opposite
whatever isn't egoism as altruism
altruism is being other regarding you
know placing others first
by contrast to dealing with what's
required for us for Aristotle this is
actually sort of a sign that things are
fundamentally mistaken and he is going
to consider a debate in his own time
that has to do with should a person be a
lover of self literally friends with
themselves or desiring or loving or
feeling affection towards themselves
over other people so he asked the
question who should we love that is
feeling feel affection towards be
friendly towards take care of who should
we love more self or others and if you
try to come up with a one side or the
yes or no sir like I lost which approach
to this Arizona thinks that you're going
to get it wrong because the line runs
through the kinds of things in relation
to which we want to be more
self-regarding or more other regarding
so he starts up with my camera saying
you know sort of the range of popular
opinion he noticed that people use this
term lover of self feel out toast and
they use it in a pejorative way that is
they think it's a bad thing for being
called a feeling I'll toast in ancient
Greece that's a sign that people think
you know somewhat badly of me
we have other language we call somebody
a selfish bastard or you know we say
they only care about number one you know
we have all sorts of interesting jargon
then we can use it every language has
the this the sort of contrast as far as
I can tell now another point that he put
in that he brings up is that the selfish
person person is they feel autos they
don't do good or noble things because
they want to they do them because
they're creative be punished they do
them because they're worried about
social sanctions they do them as we
could say unwillingly
but they use things that aren't
particularly good quite willingly you
know if it comes down to cutting some
corners so they could make an extra buck
they're perfectly happy to do that
they're not quite so happy to you know
make an exchange that goes against their
economic interest even though it's the
right thing to do you know these are not
the people who can come out to be
whistleblowers unless you offer a great
reward for whistleblowing so I think you
can see the you know the why people
would think that's a bad thing now on
the other hand Aristotle says people
could also say we should love our best
friend best and if we're good people who
is our best friend ourselves right
because we feel all the things that we
feel towards friends on the basis of how
we feel towards ourselves you know we
want our own existence we want the good
for ourselves we enjoy spending time
with ourselves we can go to this entire
yes right so there's there's a paradox
oh there is there's a conundrum there
that needs to be explorable Aristotle
says the way to resolve this issue it is
not to focus on whether a person is
simply looking to their own interests or
simply looking to another person's
interests it's rather to look at what
kind of goods are motivating them what
basis is there for the decision making
that they're engaging in
and thus the moral evaluation that we're
making from the outside of their their
behavior another way to put this is to
ask well what do you actually mean when
you say that somebody is selfish and as
a side note by the way a lot of the you
know conundrums that we face about
egoism and altruism work precisely like
this people will say well everybody's
really at bottom egoistic because you
know even the people who are doing
things to benefit other people because
they like when other people are
benefited they're really just doing that
to get something for themselves that
feeling of doing good for others yeah
you know when you hear people say stuff
like that there should be sort of a
reflection at first okay that sounds a
bit reasonable and then afterwards like
you're not even talking about the same
thing you know if you think that
enjoying another person feeling pleasure
or you know getting something that they
need is exactly the same thing as being
selfish and being willing to deprive a
thousand people of what they need so
that you get what you want you really
think those are the same thing you're
probably one of those people and we
should watch out for you
because you're laughing any sort of
genuine moral discrimination so
Aristotle is going to provide us with
you might say a dividing line for this
is moral discrimination and he says that
you know what are the things that people
when we talk about them really being
selfish in the bad sense what are we
talking about money right people get
selfish about money who's going to get
the tip who is going to buy the next
round
who's going to reciprocate after a favor
has been done that involves some money
you know people get envious right as
well I you know so-and-so is making more
money than me granted they're doing a
better job but we have the same title so
I should get the same amount as that
that's that's that kind of selfishness
that's being talked about there I can
get you know more money than you can
because I'm willing to be more assertive
with the boss so therefore I should
write that's again that kind of
selfishness honors honors covers a wide
range from you know being in the social
spotlight you know I suppose that on
YouTube the equivalent of honors would
be how many lights or positive comments
you get as opposed to thumbs down right
a little bit dishonours shares you know
all of those sorts of things would be
would be honors positions that you get
you know or even titles titles are sort
of the facsimile of positions they're
not really the position itself but
somebody gives you a fancy title and now
you feel good and you can put it on your
business card right or on your website
or whatever ever you want bodily
pleasures and there's a lot of bodily
pleasures where if I enjoy this amount
you can't enjoy it yourself
Saint Augustine has this example of you
know sexual partners and he says if
somebody using men and women if you put
your hand on this woman's thigh right
here nobody else can have their hand
there at that time that's the nature of
it objects so you can't enjoy the same
you know the same thing at the same time
and we think in terms of like food right
we can have the same meal but I can't
have the same portion that you can and
have it going into my mouth and
to my stomach that simply doesn't work
so there's some things that we do have
to divide out and can't all share them
you know we can't all participate in
them the way we can't say it in
knowledge right if I had knowledge and I
share it with you I didn't lose any
knowledge of the process as a matter of
fact perhaps the knowledge got even
greater
so with these sorts of goods money
honors bodily pleasures I think we could
think of some other things in our own
time then fit into this as well you know
when people turn conversations into a
zero-sum game perhaps time and attention
turn into something like that we talked
about the attention economy because of
the internet you know we could talk
about power we could talk about all
sorts of things along those lines people
who take more than their fair share are
viewed as being selfish
Aristotle says well why do they take
more than their fair share why is it a
bad thing it's a bad thing for other
people because other people are getting
screwed over it's a injustice right
there's there's a imbalance there it's
also bad for that it's not good to be
selfish in that way because they are
indulging their appetites that Lefou me
I you know desires for bodily pleasures
they're they're indulging all their
captions whatever they happen to be not
passion and the good sets like I have a
passion for helping people and I was not
talking about that he's was talking
about you know our emotional dries and
the irrational part of the soul this
really by being selfish in that way you
strengthen the worst parts of yourself
and make it harder for the better part
of yourself the rational part to
actually keep them in check now by
contrast we can talk about other kinds
of goods Aristotle has his wonderful
line where he says that the you know the
good person will be a lover of self in
the fullest degree in a different sense
than the lover itself called by way of
approach from whom he differs as much as
living
principle differs from living but
passion and aiming for what is noble
from aiming at what seems expedient
persons who are extreme exceptionally
zealous in noble actions are universally
admired approved commended praised they
are actually acting in a selfish way
however they feel on toast what he says
if everybody find with each other in
moral nobility and strove to perform the
noblest deeds the common welfare would
be fully realized while the individuals
also could enjoy the greatest of goods
in as much as virtue is the greatest
good that's also still being selfish but
it's being selfish in a radically
different way than this sort of
selfishness which is going after these
lesser goods that are to be goods but in
order to take a larger share we have to
sort of screw people over if I become
virtuous I will make you less virtuous
in the process as a matter of fact the
more of us that are virtuous the easier
it is for other people to become
virtuous it's not a zero-sum game at all
and being virtuous is itself a good in
fact a greater good than these other
lesser Goods so by being virtuous I am
being selfish I am being self-centered
but in a very different way in a way
that's going to benefit other people
it's not just good however because it
benefits other people this is why the
contrast between egoism and altruism
really is a badly arranged way of
thinking about things it's good for me
to be virtuous because that is what it
means for me to be a good person for
myself as well as for other people to
enjoy the good life to be on the way to
full happiness and so he says
the the good person ought to be a lover
itself since he will doesn't benefit
himself by acting nobly animate his
fellows but the bad person shouldn't be
along herself since he will follow his
base passions and injure both himself
and his neighbor's selfishness buying
itself is not a good or bad thing its
selfishness in this way and not in that
way that's a good thing and selfishness
in that way and not in this way
that is a good thing and it's based on
the character of the person and the
goods that they're going after and how
it effects everybody else he goes up a
little bit I don't have this on board
but this is very worth keeping in mind
he says it's also true that virtuous
person's conduct is often guided by the
interests of his friends and his country
and then he will if necessary lay down
his life in their behalf why that seems
to be you know supremely altruistic
right Aristotle says you would you know
you would get rid of well if you needed
to if your country needed it
and if your friends needed it you
shouldn't value those above those more
important relations
he says power all the goods men struggle
to win if you can secure nobility for
yourself if in doing what your action is
it's not just writing a check is
actually doing something that is fine
that it is noble that is commendable
that is elevated above the range of the
lower Goods right so he says such a
person would prefer now we rapture to a
long period of mild enjoyment a year of
noble life to many years of ordinary
existence one great and glorious exploit
to many small successes and it's not
just about you know getting a stanchion
for yourself or you know footnote in the
history books or an award named after
you it's about doing genuine good that
you understand to be good and you may
not actually get any
in fact somebody may not even know that
it was you who did it but that is what
the person who is motivated by the noble
will do and Aristotle thinks that in
doing so you are not being unselfish you
are not being you know you're not being
the opposite of Hillel toast you're
actually being filled out dose in the
best way so to answer the question who
should we love more solve for others the
answer is well it really depends on what
kind of goods we're talking about and
what kind of person you are because that
will affect what the meaning lover
itself turns out to be